l'année prochaine ça va faire dix ans
d'albums solo a commencé j'avais 12 ans
coiffeur 6eme rigole pas avec elsa et
ouest eva et moi avec mon groupe les
psy4 de la rime
alonso avait 12 ans c'est celle qui
cartonne aussi on l'étiré gobine tab in
town et a blessé ça c'est la non merci
est ce que tu veux qu'ils te chante je
suis en feu façon matthieu delormeau
quoi tu m'as tu peux essayer
[Applaudissements]
premier lot était
je connais qu'est ce que c'est que la
première phrase mais cela est plutôt
bien comme il est dj dan face à l'équipe
du brésil suis un peu ce soir j'ai par
la suite ce soir j'ai vu par jeffrey va
mener des glaçons aussi notre je vais
juste titre a dit jeffrey saut je vais
aller encore plus loin
si je sais on voit le match et cyril ont
fait à la bien pour les mecs en bas des
blocs en fait à l'aveyron les mecs ici
au tpm paix on le fait à leurs familles
sains comme des sopranos qui est avec
nous trente cinq soeurs regarder à 35
sur qui ça va aller
[Applaudissements]
qui va chanter pour les 35 heures happy
days avec les 35 ce mois moi j'en dis
j'ai envie qu'on fasse deux personnes ce
soir j'ai envie qu'on met non seulement
gilles verdez qui va chanter doucement
mais je vais vous dire quand même pas
nous faire happy days avec les 35 ciel
allait bien frérot viens avec moi
attention toutefois la colonne de tout
ça est ce qu'on peut mettre soprano
devant ce qu'on peuvent être surprenants
de vente il ya quand même une soeur elle
s'appellait je voudrais dire juste les
chéris ya quand même une soeur axe appel
à wisches à les responsables des images
7 h 2 o 1
merci d'envoyer merci alors venez la
bonne et la soprano venez la cervelle
gilbert des attentions
happy days avec les 35 heures on pouvait
compter chez vous ils sont bien 35 merci
d'être là dit cherry soprano et les
trente cinq soeurs pour les 35 heures
aux affidés
c'est la fête
après
[Applaudissements]
lapidaire
ce soit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
andy murray
[Musique]
hp et dell
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
jo
[Applaudissements]
m
et
[Musique]
m
abo
bonjour
là
la marque à la laddh midi dare-dare la
personne qui est là comment vous appelez
y alors à quand tu me dis bon
anniversaire à la haye un couple